the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
alright so we're going to now show some
of the examples and so again there in
our directory here examples we're now in
the sort of section 2 so we're going to
go to applications and we have a section
called power law the actual example
codes are all these ones called ppl 1 2
3 & 4 we have actually a lot of other
functions in year which are actually
really useful functions there the
functions that do all this stuff and
maybe they should actually get folded
fold into the main deform distribution
they're here right now they probably
could be cleaned up a little bit as part
of homework but these are again very
useful functions for allowing you to
generate and fit these types of things
all right so i have already started my
matlab session there we are and so we
will do the first one
going on here figures
writing
alright so if we go and look at what we
did here so the first thing we did is is
we set our parameters for our power
perfect power loss fit so we set alpha
of 1.3 a d-max of a thousand then about
you know approximately 30 mins we called
our function here which is in this
directory which is power law
distribution which will create a power
law distribution from these three
parameters and then the first thing we
did is just plot a distribution go here
we go to figure 1 you can see there is
that distribution so our perfect power
law distribution with these parameters
very nicely very nicely done then then
moving along we can compute this is how
you compute the total number vertices
from the distribution we just some give
you the know total number of edges we
can some there and then we see that the
total vertices was eighteen thousand 187
84,000 edges with an edge to vertex
ratio 4.6 we now have a function called
edges from distribution so if I pass in
the distribution essentially the degrees
and the counts it will then generate a
set of vertices that is consistent with
that distribution alright and now i'm
going to create some permutations
basically of these vertices i'm going to
create a going to randomly permute the
edge order with these two sets here so
if i basically make a random permutation
of the number of edges okay that allows
me to permute the edges and i can also
randomly permute the vertex labels
themselves and then i can look at these
different permutations to see what kind
of grass they've created so I don't
permute the data I just have a zero here
ok I just pass in the vertices that were
created I create a known on perm unit
adjacency matrix ok I can then look at
that
and that just shows you this the
adjacency matrix this isn't the blood it
just shows you that I just created a
vertex that's entirely self loops not
very interesting but nevertheless
completely consistent with a perfect
power law degree distribution so
likewise if I just permute the edges so
basically i take my permutation here and
i just perm you'd that ok this is just
not permuting the vertex labels but just
permuting the edges the next figure here
here three all right and we get this
distribution basically start vertex and
vertex looks very random fairly random
however you see the highest degree
vertices are up here at zero zero
because that's the order in which the
generator spits them out it gives you
the highest degree vertices first and so
although we've reconnected them with
different edges ok you see that they're
still there vertex labels still have an
inject intrinsic order which is
corresponding to vertex degree i should
say this generates this naturally it's a
very common way to if you have arbitrary
vertices and you want to put them on
adjacency matrix one of the first thing
to do is just to reorder them according
to degree you'll always get some kind of
structure that emerges there it's an
often an easier way to kind of see
what's going on there and as you can see
from the previous data as you saw if you
order things by degree and you saw this
type of distribution you like aha that
looks a lot like a power law
distribution just from the kind of the
scatter of the dots so moving on here so
now we're just going to permute the
vertex labels so we are not permuting
the edges just the vertex labels and so
if you see and then by permuting the
vertex labels it looks random but fairly
sparse that's because we still every
single time you know we've moved the
vertex labels around but all the edges
associated with that vertex pair still
will ship a wreck shipped around and
think we haven't done anything to break
them up whereas before we broke up the
edges but we didn't change the labels
and so then the final one which is the
one that we typically do when we want to
create random is we permute both the
vertices and the edges all right to
create sort of a truly random looking
adjacency matrix and there you see you
know something and now and now which you
can also see here is these high degree
vertices you know do stand out this is a
very standard power law distribution
you'll see these sort of dense rose and
and and columns in there that are
indicative of these very high degree
nodes when we just when we didn't when
we just / muted the edges but not the
vertices these high degree rows and
columns all got shifted up into the
corner of the plot so so again another
way to sort of begin to look at the data
in a way to sort recognize structure I
think these are Jason see matrices once
you start looking at them you begin to
certain get a comfort foam just as we do
with other types of data we begin to
learn what they what they look like this
is a very good way to look at the data
because you can look at a fair amount if
I were to actually plot the graph of
18,000 vertices as a traditional graph
of the vertices and lines connecting
them it would just be blue the entire
screen would be blue there would be no
way to properly position those vertices
I hear you know this is 84,000 data
points and I can still kind of see it a
little bit this is kind of limit a
hundred thousand edges is kind of limit
of which you can put on any plot to
really see it unless there's some sort
of hidden structures allows you to like
you know really really you know move it
all together but you know the adjacency
matrix is a great way to look at fairly
large graphs so when so though so we
generally do that so this is just this
is this is the procedure create you know
your perfect power law distribution
create some edges create some
permutations and then permute it and
then off you are you've just created a
perfect randomized perfect power log
raft again this is this is an example of
a code where you probably might even
just take this program and adjust it to
suit your needs
and then I think we did that and then
finally we plotted the degree
distribution of a three just to see that
show you that I'm not lying and again
the the triangle was the original and
the blue was the thing and you see both
through throughout all those
permutations are degree distribution
remain the same even though they look
those would be completely different
graphs their degree distributions are
are identical right so let's move on
here
alrighty so this is just showing so
we've actually rolled this up all into
one function here for you ran the
power-law matrix if you give it an alpha
a dmax and an ND it will do those three
steps for you that i had in the previous
chart all in one thing and produce an
adjacency matrix that's that's a perfect
power law based on these on these
parameters and again you saw we have the
same number of vertices that we saw in
edges and ratio that we saw before
that's all the same now we're going to
transform this data cleanup this data by
making it making it unweighted
undirected we're going to limonade self
loops we're going to take the upper
triangular part here's another one its
unweighted no self loops different
versions of them and then we do you can
see what those looks like so if we look
at the first one here so this just shows
the unweighted what unweighted just
basically making the data unweighted
does to the data set so the triangles
are the original data and just making it
unweighted how it just distorts that
that that data set go here this just
shows you what happens when you make it
undirected so unweighted means we took
everything everything all the any cases
where we had vertices with more than one
connection to them if something at five
connections now it just gets one
connection and so that was a fairly big
distortion a perfect example is like if
you take a like a person social network
graph and he were to make it unweighted
what you're saying is that the fact that
the connection you have with your spouse
is identical to with someone that you
emailed once or that you've friended
once right and I think we all agree that
that's a fair amount of information
that's lost there and so again
encouraging folks to 22 not to be aware
of that into sort of you know be careful
when they're good again making an
undirected just means we basically you
know you know if if if I phone you a lot
or I site you a lot in papers you know
that's the same as you citing me a lot
we
you lose some information there again
and this just shows the kind of
distortion that we get from just making
it undirected and then again this shows
what happens when you do nosso no self
loops well this they're not a lot of
self loops so we only have affected a
few vertices here so in this case
eliminating self loops is not a terribly
distorted doesn't really distort the
data very much at all then finally this
shows the core the upper correlation
matrix so when we correlated the two
basically multiplied you Jason same age
together again showing what we what we
saw before all right moving on
ah you get to see the plots that got
eliminated from my powerpoint matlab has
defeated powerpoints attempts to deny
you your education so alright so again
what we're doing here is we're we're
we're creating a perfect power law
alright it this is a bigger one I wanted
a lot of vertices so this time we had
50,000 vertices 329 thousand edges with
a ratio of six and a half we create our
vertices we randomize the edge order etc
now we're going to randomly pick just a
subsample of these and what is f Sam set
it its 140th so I'm just going to take
one 40th of all the vertices okay now
I'm going to go and compute that degree
and I'm going to basically subsample all
of these and later what you'll see so
let's just take a look at that so this
just shows that chart here so this is
the original data again this is the
vertex we're sorting by the vertices by
degree here so this is the highest
degree vertex these are the lowest
degree vertex ok and this each vertex is
getting a dot here so we have 50,000
vertices they all get a dot they all get
a dot here and we've only taken a 40th
um and this just shows you here you know
kind of what the few you only take a
40th of them and then compute their
sample this is what you what you get now
standard sampling sampling theory would
say AHA I know how to correct for this
the way I correct for this is i just
multiply my sample data by 40 i only
took 1 40 so that means you know
whenever I measured it the the true
value should be 40 times higher so we
can look at that in figure 2 so this is
the true sample alright so again which
we see for our high degree vertices here
this is the highest degree verdicts here
again so this is the high degree
vertices these are the low degree
vertices I know if I said that opposite
when I mentioned it before this is the
highest degree verdicts and you see that
by sampling the data we're doing a very
good job on the high degree vertices
we're sampling them just fine and that's
that's kind of why statistics works
right you know if you if something is
really not rare any sample you're going
to get you're going to get a good
estimate however for these low degree
vertices over here what you see by
multiplying by 40 were significantly
overestimating their probability all
right as I say this is the curve that
proves that optimists and pessimists are
both correct there are so many rare
things that if the world is a power-law
distribution it means that there are so
many rare events in the world some of
them are going to happen to you so it
means if you're an optimist go play the
lottery all right if you're pessimist it
means yeah lightning could hit you and
you better just be you know stick and
stay inside so there's just so many rare
things that you know some of them are
going to some really rare things are
going to happen to you in your lifetime
most likely those rare things that were
very mundane you know so so but we can
correct for this and so we have some
some basically a way here of deriving
calculations we compute the parameters
of our distribution and through these
two functions compute degree correction
and apply degree correction we can
actually go back and sort of say all
right given that we believe the data is
power law and we've sampled it can we
then come up with a more uniform
correction that basically gives us a
better estimate that works at both the
high in the low end and that's what you
see here so basically we haven't changed
the correction hasn't changed here but
we've lowered we've downgraded these
lower ones and essentially what we're
doing is instead of just using the
average as the statistic we're using the
median so we're using essentially a
quantile based a correction here a
fiftieth percent quantile based
correction here and that causes us to
lower the estimates of these vertices
and so there would be a better estimate
in terms allow you to do to the sampling
of that alright very good
and our final demo
right so now what we're doing is doing
power law fitting okay and so we have
the routines for doing that so again
here's our distribution to a power law
of 1.3 we've set D max to be 2000 and
about 60 ish bins we create our parallel
distribution it has 50,000 vertices 329
thousand edges ratio so the same as the
one we did before we're going to make it
undirected undirected unweighted
undirected unweighted no self loops so
sort of standard Corrections that we do
going to compute the degree distribution
of that data and plot it or actually get
there now I'm going to then we have this
function called power law fit so if I
compute this is I'm going to compute so
I compute the degree distribution so
this function called AB degree which
just gives us the distribution I can
find essentially the number of values
with that one and the one that our
maximum to get our this is estimating
our poor man's slope so we're computing
the slope we're counting the total
number of edges here and then we have
this function called power law fit
basically we can plug in what the
estimated alpha is with the number of
vertices is the number of edges is to
find our best fit distribution so this
basically inverts those two those
formulas i showed you which is given a
degree distribution that sums to a
particular number of vertices and sums
to a particular number of edges can you
give me a new d max and a new ND these
sort of parameters that don't really
have as much meaning to to do that and
so basically we use essentially a
combination of three different
techniques here because this is so
nonlinear and there's this basically we
remember i talked about integer bins and
logarithmic bins if you look at that
plot it showed there's that sort of
bending so very sort of nasty manifold
the surface of this function it has a
continuous part in discrete part so what
we do here is we do us essentially a
sampled search where we kind of ran
namely sample looking for a location we
do a heuristic search which is sort of a
kind of a simulated annealing search and
we also uses Brighton's a nonlinear
essentially a variation of Newton's
method to all try and find the best set
of parameters that will fit this data we
never we rarely get an exact match but
you can see here is choosing different
ones and this gives you the kind of how
it's doing from the sample search this
shows you the number of vertices and the
number of edges it was able to achieve
the heuristic search you know didn't do
very well at all and then the Brighton's
search did a pretty good job you know it
I inning and it got it got us a pretty
well so Choi first thing it chose it oxi
actually it ended up comparing all of
these and it ended up choosing the the
sample search this one this first one it
did it like that best of all so you look
at that here so figure 2 just was the
original original data figure 1 shows
you the manifold of this space and so
plotted in this this coordinate system
of n versus em the dot is the lot that
it found its actually here in this type
in this type of partnering these lines
show the boundaries but you can see this
sort of very nonlinear manifold here
this is sort of the continuous regime
this is the integer regime it cusps
right at the transition again a very
nasty function to try and try and
inverting which is why we used all those
different techniques to invert it and
then and then figure 3 shows the results
so this black line shows the original
model input that we provided so that was
the the true model the circle shows the
data after was transformed we made it
undirected unweighted with no self loops
that's this alpha is this is our our
poor man's alpha which you can see is
almost identical to the original model
so the even the poor man's alpha does a
very good job of fitting in this case
this shows the triangle shows the model
fit
so when we fit the data we came up with
that best fit it shows and we then
created a new distribution this is what
it looked like and then the plus sign
shows us rebidding that data onto the
bins from the model and you see that
we've done a very nice job of recovering
the original power-law distribution
after even after we did that distortion
so again that sort of is the last
example so I want to thank you and then
for the homework a lot of you did home
or two which is great I think homework
three wasn't such a great hit I'm going
to definitely rethink that one but the
next homer does not require you to have
done homework three if you did homework
too basically it's just saying compute a
degree distribution okay and in fact you
don't even need to have done homework to
just you can compute a degree
distribution on your homework too or you
can compute a degree distribution on any
data set for example today is Halloween
do you go trick-or-treating with your
with with somebody yourself your
children somebody else's children you
can you can maybe email me what the do
you know the histogram of your candy and
plot it on a degree distribution I maybe
compute the the poor man's alpha
coefficient from that and the other you
know coefficients from that would be a
fun exercise to do so that'll be the
next homework i'll email that out in the
next couple of days and so look forward
again if you send me the homework prior
to the next actual just reminder no
class next week no class next week this
room is being taken so but again if you
email me the homework prior to this time
next week i will give you feedback on it
um it's still sent me the homework after
that I just won't give you any feedback
on it so thank you again and look
forward to seeing you in two weeks